the values of the definite integral from
0 to 1 of X to the fourth times 1 minus
X to the fourth all of that over 1 plus
x squared DX is or are and they say are
because more than one of these might be
the correct answer this is one of those
multiple correct answer problems so this
is just a straight-up definite integral
and it looks like the best way to do it
is really just expand out the numerator
see if we can simplify that with the
denominator and then just try to take
the antiderivative so let's do that so
first let's expand 1 minus X 1 minus X
to the fourth and when you're taking the
binomial to the fourth power
to remember the coefficients you of
course can use the traditional binomial
coefficients but I find it easier just
to use Pascal's triangle to remember
what the coefficients are so if you have
a binomial if you square it the
coefficients are 1 1 plus 1 is 2 and
then 1 and I've done several videos
where I explain why this works and if
you take you the third part of the
coefficients are 1 3 3 and 1 I'm just
adding the two the two branches that add
up that point to that one node there I
guess you can view it that way and if
you take it to the fourth power the
coefficients are 1 4 6 4 and 1 so if we
want to take 1 minus X to the fourth
power and I'm going to write it like
this I'm going to write it as negative X
plus 1 to the fourth power and I want to
do it that way because I want the
high-degree X terms to be listed first
then this is going to be this is going
to be so we're going to start with this
term at the highest power then this term
is the zero power and then each
successive term this term is going to
lower in power and this one is going to
go up in power so it's going to be
negative x to the fourth times 1 to the
0 I'll just write it here times 1 to the
0 plus the coefficient of that first one
was just at 1 so plus 4 plus 4 times
negative x to the 3rd times 1 to the 1
power plus now we have our 6 plus 6
times negative x squared times 1 squared
the core another way to think about it
is the the exponents on the 1 and the
negative x should always add up to 4 and
then you have plus now we're at this 4
plus 4 times
negative X times 1 to the 3rd times 1 to
the 3rd and then plus 1 to the 4th power
or negative x to the 0 times 1 to the
4/3 which is usually just 1 to the 4th
power so this is going to simplify 2 so
negative x to the 4th negative x to the
4th is the same thing as X to the 4th
negative 1 to the 4th is just 1 times 1
plus well actually I should say minus
because negative x to the third is
negative x to the 3rd so this is minus
4x to the 3rd so we've done that term
this term will become positive negative
x squared same thing as x squared so
it's plus 6x squared and then this is
negative 4x negative 4x plus 1 plus 1
now we want to multiply this whole thing
that we just expanded times X to the 4th
so let's multiply that whole thing times
X to the 4th so if we so the expression
X to the 4th times 1 minus X all of that
all of that to the 4th power is going to
be equal to we'll just multiply this
times X to the 4 that's pretty
straightforward it's going to be X to
the 8th minus 4x to the seventh plus 6 X
to the 6th minus 4x to the 5th plus X
plus X to the fourth now we want to
divide this bottom expression into the
top expression so we just can just use
some algebraic long division so we want
to divide and I'll write it as x squared
plus 1 we want to divide x squared plus
1 into this big thing into this thing
right here so let me copy and paste that
we want to divide it into this and we're
going to break out some algebraic long
division to do it so let me draw the
division division symbol right over
there and so we just say we look at the
highest degree terms on every step x
squared goes into X to the 8th X to the
6 times so we put in the X to the sixth
place X is 6 times x squared is X to the
8th X to the 6 times 1 is X to the sixth
and then we subtract this from the
number up here the expression up here
X
- exited is nothing negative 4x to the
seventh minus nothing is negative 4x to
the seventh 6x - 6 - 6 minus X to the
sixth is plus 5x to the 6 this and then
these you're subtracting nothing from
them so it's minus 4x to the fifth plus
X to the fourth now X 2 squared or x
squared goes into X to the seventh or it
goes into negative 4x to the seventh
negative 4x to the fifth times negative
4x to the 5th times let's scroll down a
little bit negative 4x to the fifth
times x squared is negative 4x to the
seventh negative 4x to the 5th times 1
is negative 4x to the 5th now we
subtract this from that these cancel out
these cancel out and we are left with we
are left with 5x to the sixth + + X to
the fourth plus X to the fourth x
squared goes into 5 X to the sixth 5x to
the fourth times so plus 5x to the
fourth I just arbitrarily switch to
colors the yellow is becoming monotonous
5x to the fourth times x squared scroll
down some more 5x to the fourth times x
squared is 5 X to the sixth 5x to the
fourth times 1 is 5x to the fourth 5x to
the fourth and now we subtract or we
could we just subtract those cancel out
X to the fourth minus 5x to the fourth
is negative 4x to the fourth nothing to
bring down x squared goes into negative
x to the fourth
it goes into it negative 4x squared
times negative 4x squared times negative
4x squared times x squared is negative
4x to the fourth negative 4x squared
times 1 is negative 4 is negative 4x
squared and now we subtract that from
that you subtract 0 you subtract this
from 0 or 0
- negative 4x squared is going to be
positive 4x squared positive forks where
all of these steps were all
subtracting I should draw the
subtraction symbol right over there and
then x squared goes into 4x squared
we're in the homestretch it goes into it
four times so plus four four times x
squared is 4x squared four times one is
four and then we subtract one last time
we subtract this whole thing these
cancel out and then we're just left with
a remainder of negative four so this
whole thing this whole expression over
here simplifies to this plus negative
four over x squared plus one let me
rewrite it let me copy and paste it so
it turns into this so copy and then let
me paste it down here wasted a lot of
real estate paste so it turns into this
this and then we have the minus four
minus four over over the x squared plus
1 so minus four over over x squared
minus four over x squared plus one so
this is the entire expression that we
have inside of inside of the integral so
this is the same thing as the integral
of this from 0 to 1 0 to 1 times DX so
now we just have to take the
antiderivative of this and this looks
pretty straightforward the only kind of
complicated part is this right here but
you might recognize you might recognize
that the derivative with respect to X of
arctangent of X is equal to 1 over x
squared plus 1 so that kind of
simplifies this part for us so let's
tackle the problem so let's just take
the antiderivative this is pretty
straightforward
antiderivative we just of to make sure
we don't have it make a careless mistake
antiderivative X to the sixth is going
to be X to the seventh over seven I mean
I should say 1/7 X is 7 antiderivative
of this is negative 4 negative 4 6 which
is the same thing as negative 2/3 X to
the sixth antiderivative of that is X to
the fifth plus X to the fifth right I'm
just raising the exponent so that's
where I get the X to the fifth and I
divide
by that exponent so 5 divided by 5 is 1
and then I have X to the third or it's
negative 4/3 X to the third negative 4/3
X to the third plus 4 X plus 4 X and
then minus 4 minus 4 arc tangent of X
arc tangent arc tangent of X so let's
think about this a little bit so we're
going to evaluate it at 1 and then
subtract from that it evaluated at 0 so
we need to evaluate this at 1 and then
from that subtract it at 0 so if you
evaluate it one you have 1/7 minus 2/3
plus 1 minus 4/3 minus 4/3 + 4 plus 4
that's plus 4 right over there and then
minus 4 arctangent of 1 minus 4
arctangent arctangent of 1 so let's
think about what the arctangent of 1 is
so the arctangent of 1 is essentially
saying if I have a right triangle if I
have a right triangle if I take the
opposite over the adjacent so the
opposite is telling us that it's telling
us so the tan so it's telling us give us
the angle so we're looking for this
angle we're looking for the angle where
the tangent where the tangent of this
angle is equal to 1 or another way to
say it is that the opposite over the
adjacent is equal to 1 or another way to
say it is that the opposite is equal to
the adjacent the opposite is equal to
the adjacent so this side has to be
equal to this side this is going to be a
slope of 1 right over here now
we could you know try to look at you
know different types of triangles and it
might pop out at you what kind this is
but you can just go to basic geometry to
think about this this is a right angle
right here these two sides are equal
these two angles are equal so these two
angles have to evenly split the
remaining 90 degrees in the triangle
because it adds up to 180 so this is a
45 degree 45-degree angle but in general
when they just when they don't tell you
what whether you're in radians or
degrees at least on most exams I've see
and you should just assume that you are
in
so 45 degrees is the same thing let's
see pi is 180 degrees PI over 2 is 90
degrees PI over 4 is 45 degrees so this
is equal to that right over there is PI
over 4 radians so this over here is PI
over 4 radians or I could just say PI
over 4 or another way to think about it
tangent of PI over 4 is equal to 1 so
this is just the inverse function so
these two cancel out so this this
simplifies to so I just evaluated it at
1 so let me before I move forward let me
subtract from that this whole thing
evaluated at 0 and this is a little bit
more straightforward all of these things
are going to be 0 when you evaluate at 0
and what's the arctangent of 0 well
tangent of 0 is 0 if this angle was 0 if
you just had a flat line then your slope
is flat so this is just going to be 0 so
this whole thing evaluated at 0 is going
to be 0 so the whole value of our
definite integral is going to be this
thing over here so it's going to be all
of this stuff and then this last term
this last term right over here this last
term right over here is negative 4 times
pi over 4 which so it's going to be
negative PI and all of these are going
to add up to some number without a PI in
it so if you were under time pressure
it's actually a good idea to just look
at the answers before we even add up all
of those fractions say which of these
have a negative PI in them and only one
of them has a negative PI in them so our
answer our answer is most probably going
to be this if you're under time pressure
I would just circle that is clearly not
any of these none of these have a
negative PI in them and there's no way
that that negative PI can get altered by
this stuff over here so you wouldn't
even have to worry about adding it but
since we want to make sure we have the
right answer let's add up all of these
fractions so let's think about what we
can do here so if we have so we have let
me try my so we have so let's see
negative 2/3 minus 4/3 let me take those
two terms negative 2/3 minus 4/3 is
negative 6 thirds or negative 2 so those
become negative 2 plus 1 plus 4 so plus
1 plus 4 and then plus 1/7 plus 1/7 so
this is 3 plus 1
7:3 plus 1/7 and of course we have the
negative pi out there minus pi and this
is the same thing as 21 over 7 plus 1/7
minus Pi which is equal to 22 over 7
minus pi so that is indeed the only
answer 22 over 7 minus pi and we're done